i did what i had to do
to protect our world
it's pretty unfathomably exciting where
we're going in this film
it's the most fantastic new phase of
marvel
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
dangerous
in this story we are leaping into
different universes but unlocking the
multiverse creates a big pandora's box
you open the doorway and we don't know
who or what will walk through it
we're in unknown territory
i think audiences are going to be
startled these other realities invite a
plethora of all these new characters
[Music]
telling the stories was such a gigantic
endeavor
it had to be large because it had to not
only paint a picture of our universe but
of multiple universes
we need your help it was a great
opportunity to pair two of the most
powerful superheroes together
it's got a sort of darker tone to it
than with sam raimi at the helm and he's
a master of that
we wanted the fans to go oh how cool i
mean that really was our goal we wanted
to give the fans what they wanted just
not exactly what they expected
the stakes are real he's literally
coming up against versions of himself
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you